ouellet
op
je
on va faire ce temps j'aimerais bien que
de toute façon absolument pas de base à
l'accord passé quatre boutons vous
prendrez les boutons qu'on a pris une
autre fois déjà la ceinture au philippin
secours ont été engagés
énerve
itunes
madoff est
en fait
les décisions français
ap
la rituelle j'ai un de vos très joli
manteau la plaine poche mais pas de
phrases clés quelle est elle je provoque
et je veux cette agression c'est à votre
égard ou à l'égard des autres pas
spécialement à mon égard pas
spécialement à l'égard des autres à
l'égard de tout de moi même plutôt je
crois depuis quand êtes-vous créatrice
de mode depuis 4 5 ans et quand vous est
venue cette idée
je provoque et je veux je sais pas il ya
très longtemps depuis toujours depuis
que je suis toute petite je crois que
j'ai toujours propos que les shows j'ai
toujours été une enfant dur difficile
avec des tas de problèmes et j'ai
toujours tout provoquer mais vous n'avez
pas fait la mode des autres non j'ai
fait ma mode à moi c'est à dire que j'ai
décidé pour moi et en fonction de moi et
les gens sont venus à moi c'est à dire
que ils ont décidé d'un seul coup qu'ils
étaient tous en fait à toutes les femmes
à peu près fait comme moi et elle avait
envie de d'être comme moi tout
simplement
et ce sont elles qui sont venus à moi ça
n'est pas moi qui suis allé à elle sonia
rykiel vous avez dit dans votre magasin
que les femmes vous suivait c'est très
important pour vous qu'on vous remarque
qu'on vous suive une bille quand je
crois depuis toujours je crois que
quand je suis né je suis né avec une
tête toute rouge c'est à dire que elle
était tellement rouchon nar frictionner
à l'eau oxygénée parce qu'on pensait que
j'étais tout en sang or si j'avais des
cheveux complètement et je pense que
c'était déjà une provocation c'est à
dire que ma mère en me donnant le sein
le disait tout le temps mais pourquoi tu
es rouge pourquoi tu es roussel était
fasciné par tes cheveux complètement
rouge et je crois que ça a été ma
première provocation c'est à dire que
depuis que je suis tout petit
quand les gens me regardent dans la rue
y font ils regardent et puis il se
retourne une deuxième fois d'un air de
dire n est pas vrai je sais pas c'est un
peu anormal quand j'ai commencé à
travailler les gens n'ont pas du tout
cru en moi c'est à dire que des amis
très très à tignes on pensait que ce que
je faisais c'était des idées un peu
prise par tous un peu de copies un peu
de de stylisme arrangé et un jour nous
sommes fâchés avec des amis très chers
justement parce que
ils m'ont provoquer ils ont ils m'ont
pratiquement interdit la porte de leur
magasin et j'ai eu une espèce de sursaut
qui a fait que je suis devenu
certainement c'est à dire que je me suis
dit c'est pas possible que les gens
pensent ça c'est pas possible que les
gens ne croient pas en moi parce que
j'avais l'impression que toujours tout
le monde croyait en moi et ça a provoqué
ce que je suis devenu je crois enfin il
me semble comment voulez vous la femme
la femme je la veux pas du tout c'est à
dire que ça ne m'intéresse pas ce qui
est très important c'est quand même la
fête de la femme c'est bête parce que je
fais des vêtements donc c'est
complètement idiot que je dis que ce qui
est important c'est la tête donc c'est
pas du tout mes vêtements
mais je prends que l'on la bible où elle
s'habille avec la fin c'est à dire que
elle décide elle même si vous voulez la
chose dont je me souviens la maintenant
dans l'instance et il y a quatre ans la
première fois que j'ai porté un pantalon
dans paris en semaine en allant déjeuner
avec un ami
j'avais un rendez vous d'affaires et je
suis arrivé en pantalon et cet ami m'a
dit est ce que tu veux venir déjeuner
avec moi au fouquet's j'étais juste un
petit peu interdits parce que je
trouvais que le fouquet's était
peut-être a tellement l'endroit rêvé
avec un pantalon ni puisqu'il était
d'accord je l'étais aussi et nous sommes
allés déjeuner au fouquet's
je suis arrivé là-bas et il ya eu
quelque chose de terrible c'est que
c'était pas moi du tout qu'il était gêné
c'était tout le monde parce que les gens
ne savaient pas et c'était les avait
l'air beaucoup plus gêné que moi moi
j'étais très à l'aise en définitive les
hommes disent quelquefois que portait un
bandage ont fait perdre à la femme sa
féminité
qu'en pensez vous contre
comment je travaille d'abord je
travaille tout le temps je n'ai pas
l'air mais quand je conduis je travaille
quand je joue aux cartes je travaille
quand je fais la cuisine je travaille je
fais des très bonnes tard
je suis extrêmement dur dans mon travail
c'est à dire que je n'y connais rien je
ne sais pas coupé je ne sais pas le
droit donc je suis encore beaucoup plus
dur que je crois que ceux qui savent
parce que quand on me dit ça n'est pas
possible je dis tu dois le faire et on
le fait toujours